how would you describe 2020
to someone that had been in a coma since
christmas well i mean
it's not really very different to what
i've been saying this whole time
it's just that here is all come to
fruition i mean it's
it's really weird listening to um
mainstream voices basically sound like
my 2017 videos
and it's really interesting that
essentially everything i was saying
this is not just um what we are seeing
is not just people complaining
about police brutality right this is
fundamentally a communist revolution
that has been brewing
in academia teaching a generation
to think that capitalism and the west is
evil
and this gives the moral license to tear
it all down i mean
a statue of george washington was torn
down in portland the other day
because apparently he was a slave-owning
racist it's like well
i mean you know the united states is
going to be tainted by this original sin
that it can never
overcome ex and obviously we are as well
and so this this just means that these
people have an emotional
um sort of disposition against the thing
that they're attacking
like they they i don't think they'll
ever be able to become patriotic again
because they've been emotionally
conditioned to hate that thing
you know like it
they the demands they're going to make
are also
going to be insane which they are like
to get rid of the police and things like
this and
you'll see here people say oh no we just
want to you know police reform [ __ ]
you know the the activists the radicals
the people who are actually driving this
are quite open they want to get rid of
the police and that would be
i mean there have been examples of
police going on strike and it
within hours devolves into an anarchic
situation and
we can see from the chairs or the chop
as they're calling it now
that this isn't exactly a productive way
of life
is it you know we have law and order and
justice you know judiciary and the
government for a reason
as as evil as they can be at times
we still do need them in general you
know
so um basically we have to understand
that this is a communist revolution that
we are watching which is why they do all
the same things as previous communist
revolutions
like setting up a commune you know uh
tearing down the established
order the statues of the established
order and they're just very open about
saying they want to get rid of
capitalism
like black lives matter did a fundraiser
in the uk that's probably earned over a
million pounds now it was 750 when i
last looked at it
and on the on the first line it's like
we're here to dimensional dismantle
capitalism imperialism white supremacy
hetero patriarchy and stuff like that
and people are looking at nigel farage
and farage is
finally saying well look these people
are actually communists who are here to
take over capitalism
which i was saying and everyone's like
well
you can't prove him wrong can you not in
the first line none of that stuff sounds
to me like the first the best way to
progress black people in this world it's
not the best way to do anything
it's that's the problem the problem with
communism is it's a religion
masquerading
as an economic system like nobody would
want no nobody would question
what side is more productive like when
the soviet union fell
they americans sent economists over
there to do an analysis and they
basically
found that they were earning about half
as much as they could be just given what
they had
it's just that the means of distribution
being centralized and top down
demolish any kind of incentive like when
you take away
the security of the protection of your
own private property
you've got no reason to get up every day
and start building something you know
why would you this can be taken away
from you
and so it's very difficult to motivate
people um
and it's obvious this is the case but
it's not about that what it's about is
establishing
something that they can feel is perfect
and moral because it's all predicated on
morality
like it like they'll say things like
capitalism will never end inequality
well no that's true but inequality is
such a fundamental part of diversity
that why would it even be desirable to
do that if we were all equal we'd have
to be all the same and therefore there's
no diversity like there's a natural
difference there's always going to be
people at different heights and if you
want everyone to be the same then your
only option is the lowest common
denominator
because you can't raise up people who
aren't going to be raised and you'll
have to pull down people
who otherwise wouldn't stay at the
bottom rung um
but yeah so essentially we have to deal
with it in these terms
it's it's a moral crusade that the
communists are on
and they literally don't think there's
anything moral about our system
which they've pathologized as whiteness
even if it's not necessarily white it's
there's a number of black people that
can be on that other side of the fences
if you don't agree with
a particular ideology so how how has
this year
fitted together how do you think that
coronavirus contributed to this or trump
being impeached or the impending general
election the
american presidential election have you
got some sort of conception of how that
fits together does it even all fit
together well
i think that the coronavirus um
i i don't know you get people saying oh
this probably accelerated things so well
maybe i
don't you know i honestly i don't think
anyone can really be sure of that so i'm
not gonna
suggest that's an uh causal factor
especially as i don't think it needs to
have been in play to be a causal factor
um it could just be that it set the
stage
but i but the the tinder you know you
know
like but the tinder was already there
you know it was already ready for the
match to be flicked into it maybe it
just packed it more tightly so the
explosion was bigger or something but
like the what what we've been seeing
is the results of a consistent pattern
of activism
from a consistent set of beliefs that
have recognizable
public figures as adherents and thought
leaders
uh robin d'angelo is the person who's
like trending
in these spheres at the moment her book
white fragility was at number one so
it's and it's worth reading
because it's unapologetic i mean i made
i was reading it earlier i made some
notes huh let me just
read you a quick line or something from
it because it's just crazy
um the the
the whole point um
is she thinks she's saying to white
people what people of color can't tell
us
and she views white
culture as being like and
she just says white because it's in the
american context but she's talking about
the sort of anglo-saxon protestant
european culture that america was
founded on because of the
english colonies she views that as a
kind of
ethnic attack on non-white people
that's what whiteness is and that's what
white supremacy is existing
not not just by existing uh but yes it
is just by existing but the
it's in the way that it is different to
these other cultures
it's uh individualistic and meritocratic
for example these are the two big
pillars that she uses about whiteness
um which yeah it would be you would
expect that it's
it comes from england which is an
individualistic society
and it's meritocratic because it's a
protestant society it's very
geared around personal hard work uh this
has been a
like a moral tradition
in england you know you you and it
infects every part of the culture so
like you know when you're poor you're
ashamed of being poor because the
implication
in the english moral system is that
you've been lazy
right it's that you are a free man you
know this is this was the point of being
a free man is that you had control of
your life and if you're poor
that means you're not working very hard
right that's i'm not saying it's the
case
it's just the moral implication of the
thing um
and so that's why the shame attached to
being poor in in english cultures
um but the the the whole structure the
the individualistic memocratic that is a
form of racism
in and of itself that's the racist thing
and
that's what white europeans do in
america and therefore
whiteness which is the desire for an
individualistic meritocratic culture
needs to be destroyed and what she's
doing
is trying to create a kind of white
identity that is effectively laden with
the
presumably catholic guilt that missed
d'angelo has
held over from her her parents and
load this identity onto people saying
look whiteness is a form of oppression
it is inherently racist you need to you
know understand that you're someone who
perpetuated by having standards by
wanting
to be treated like an individual to be
you know to be concerned about
merit to be concerned about skill in the
things that are going on rather than
arbitrary and i'd and expressly identity
politics category she's just open saying
no i'm
arguing from identity politics for white
people
so in many ways she's actually very
similar to richard spencer because that
was exactly his message
do you want to become a nazi that's your
option d'angelo is offering it and i'm
saying no to that no no way i'm not
becoming a white identitarian even if it
comes laden with guilt
and i have to prostrate myself i mean
this is why this is why you're seeing
you know um
the ceo of chick-fil-a shining a black
guy's shoes on stage so oh yeah
brilliant shoe shining forced racial
shoe shining that's the path to racial
harmony isn't it
you know i mean that's surely the thing
you're saying that was done wrong
in the past and yet they're like oh yeah
i'm gonna no we're not shining each
other's shoes okay
we're not doing that that's totally
disrespectful which is what you were
objecting to
you know and so we're not gonna do it
and somehow make record
recompense or reparations out of this
this humiliating
you